[Music]
on this Saturday night close call at Sea
a global news crew bearing witness to a
near catastrophic collision between U.S
and Chinese warships labeled intentional
the fact that this was announced over
the radio prior to doing it our
Mackenzie gray brings us an exclusive
report from the South China Sea also
tonight the helping hand from above this
is not a heavy downpour that runs off
and disappears bringing relief to Nova
scotia's fire fights
the sex torsion crisis hitting Canadian
high schools I don't think anyone's safe
pictures get altered it could be a
different person with a different face
different body looks like they're doing
something completely different the
proposed Federal Crackdown and
provincial push to stop it and a daring
descent on Mount Everest
the rescue and escape from the mountains
Death Zone
global national with Fara Nasser
good evening to you and thanks for
joining us we begin tonight with an
exclusive report from one of the most
contentious waterways in the world the
South China Sea our Global News crew has
been traveling with the Canadian Navy
and earlier today witnessed firsthand
the latest aggressive move by Beijing
appearing to intentionally Target a U.S
vessel escalating tensions between these
two Global superpowers
the dangerous maneuver happened in the
Taiwan Straits where hmcs Montreal has
been traveling part of operation
projection a joint military Mission
between Canada and the U.S our camera
captured this Chinese warship picking up
speed before cutting in front and nearly
colliding with the bridge wing of the
U.S Destroyer Mackenzie gray is aboard
the Canadian frigate and he saw it all
happen in front of him Mackenzie Farah
we've just completed an 18-hour journey
of the Taiwan Strait Here on hmcs
Montreal and we were joined by an
American Destroyer that had a close
encounter with the Chinese warship
our trip to the most politically charged
Waters in the world started off as
anti-climactic the only thing visible
were the calm seas but we did know there
was a friend close by when the Navy
travels through this part of the world
they're generally accompanied by Allied
chip right here is a U.S warship that
will be traveling with the Montreal
through the Taiwan Strait that ship USS
chung-hoon it's been with the Montreal
the past few days but so of Chinese
warships shadowing the rare joint U.S
Canada mission in the South China Sea
but from a distance
once the fog cleared in the Taiwan
Strait we shot this video of one of the
Chinese ships stepping up their
aggression picking up considerable steam
coming in from the left telling the
Chung Hoon over the radio to move or
there'd be a collision the Americans
told the Chinese to stay clear of their
ship But ultimately they were cut off
and needed to slow down to avoid getting
hit the two ships missing each other by
only 150 yards when you're in big
warships maneuvering close to each other
150 yards is is very scary and you don't
ever want to be that close to another
vessel because too many things can go
wrong and you can actually have a
collision that's hmcs Montreal Commander
Paul mountford he watched the incident
and believes the Chinese broke
International Maritime regulations and
acted unprofessionally the fact that
this was announced over the radio prior
to doing it clearly indicated that was
intentional the Chinese ships didn't
attempt to similar maneuver on the
Montreal but did get within 1 000 yards
of the ship I'm hoping that that was an
isolated incident that that won't happen
again for us because we have
international law on our side this is
this is international waters as the day
moved on so did the Chinese drifting
further and further away from the
Canadian U.S ships as they continue
their course right through the contested
Waters the Montreal has now left the
Taiwan Strait but Chinese warships are
still shadowing it but it's the near
collision with the U.S warship Farah
they could have done real damage to the
china-u.s relationship
Mackenzie gray aboard hmcs Montreal for
us tonight thank you for your coverage
Mackenzie and what Mackenzie just showed
us is not an isolated incident in fact
the Pentagon says there's been an
alarming increase of aggressive
intercepts by Chinese military aircraft
and vessels in a disputed region
including on Friday last week when a
Chinese fighter jet flew in front of a
U.S reconnaissance plane Beijing is
building and fortifying artificial
islands and is able to deploy its
military at a moment's notice Canada's
defense minister Anita Anand is in
Singapore for a top security Summit and
today revealed that Canada will boost
its military presence in the region
David Akin reports
at a security Summit in Singapore
Canada's defense minister Anita Anand
was meeting with her counterparts from
around the world the topic of the day
China Canada always seeks coexistence
and collaboration we will challenge
China where we ought to we will
cooperate with China to find Solutions
on global issues but almost at the same
time an incident in the Taiwan Strait
caught by a Global News television crew
it's the latest in a series of
provocative acts by the Chinese military
basically they're they're bullying and
provoking reactions to say that these
are their Waters and that we we
shouldn't be there Anon spoke to global
news about the incident later in the day
Canada will continue to sail where
international law allows including the
straight the South China Sea and really
our overall goal is to increase the
peace and stability of this region and
that's why we are going to continue to
see more of Canada in this region as set
out in our indo-pacific strategy at the
summit on unannounced Canada will
increase its Naval presence in the
Pacific sending two rather than one Navy
frigate on an annual deployment in the
region those at the Singapore Summit had
hoped that top U.S and Chinese defense
officials could find a way to
de-escalate tensions in the region but
the U.S said that China refused to talk
a brief handshake at dinner was all that
could be managed
cordial handshake over dinner is no
substitute for a substantive engagement
and the more that we talk the more we
can avoid the misunderstandings and
miscalculations that could lead to
crisis or conflict the Chinese said the
Americans were to blame
this is because of a series of erroneous
actions and words made by the U.S side
this Chinese General said Australia's
prime minister warned of the
consequences of this breakdown in
dialogue the consequences of such a
breakdown whether in the Taiwan stride
or elsewhere would not be confined to
the big powers or the side of their
conflict
that would be devastating for the world
David Aiken Global News
Ottawa
search crews are still working to find
survivors after India's worst real
disaster in more than two decades
the death toll has now reached 300
people with another 1 000 among the
injured a preliminary report shows the
crash happened because of a signal
failure some of the mangled train cars
have now been cleared and taken away by
cranes
finally some relief rain is offering a
helping hand for those fighting
wildfires in Nova Scotia and there's
even more good news for those in the
Halifax area the fire there is no longer
deemed out of control our Mike Armstrong
has been covering the fires all week and
joins us in what looks like much needed
rain normal times a rainy weekend isn't
something people look forward to but for
much of Nova Scotia right now this is
very much not normal times this weather
is welcome
for the crews fighting fires it isn't
just that there is rain it's the type of
rain basically it's exactly what they
need this is excellent this is not a
heavy downpour that runs off and
disappears this will soak into the
ground more effectively
for the last few days Crews haven't been
dealing with big flames it's been mostly
about searching for hot spots on the
ground meter by meter today is going to
be probably an uncomfortable day for
people out there they're going to be
digging they're going to be moving logs
they're going to be they're going to be
in the black and it's going to be real
messy
now some areas of the evacuation Zone
have been reopened residents in the
green areas of this map are now allowed
home
if that's meant for many is going back
to houses that had no power for days
people are having to empty fridges and
freezers
y busy day but you know what where the
lucky ones
that perspective was something heard
often Saturday but 150 homes in Upper 10
Talon were destroyed residents returning
home know they're lucky to have a home
to return to
it was great to be back we were just
thankful that uh things weren't a whole
lot worse all we lost was food and
compared to what other people have lost
that's nothing the Rain Is Lifting
Spirits Nova scotia's Premier spent the
day in the southwestern part of the
province a region where firefighters are
still battling what he calls the biggest
fire in provincial history the
Barrington Lake Fire covers more than 23
000 hectares and is still considered out
of control but 50 homes have been lost
all new firefighting resources headed to
the province are being deployed to that
region Mike Armstrong Global News upper
10 Talon Nova Scotia
tragedy in Quebec four children have
died and one person is missing after a
fishing trip gone wrong on the shores of
the Saint Lawrence River
the children were initially found
unresponsive hours after an overnight
where a group fishing on the riverbank
was caught by a rising tide they were
taken to a nearby Health Center and were
later pronounced dead search efforts are
now underway for the missing man in his
30s six other people were rescued from
the water
conservative leader Pierre pauliev is
urging NDP leader jugmit Singh to pull
out of the NDP liberal confidence and
Supply agreement hoping to trigger an
election over the prime minister's
refusal to call a public inquiry into
foreign interference but Singh says that
won't solve the problem for the West
block Mercedes Stevenson sat down with
him and NDP MP Jenny Kwan
you will not hold them accountable you
will not put an election on the table as
a possibility aren't you kind of
handcuffing yourself there well not at
all because we can still raise the
concerns we can still raise the issues
but there's no real consequence for them
at the end of the day well the
consequence of an election would
undermine if my true goal is to defend
democracy it would be illogical to say
I'm concerned about our democracy being
influenced by Foreign governments so I'm
going to trigger an election that that
doesn't actually fit together logically
if someone is self-serving like Mr
pauliev and Mr Blanche who just wants an
election and is looking for an excuse
then I would understand that argument
but I actually genuinely want to see the
full extent of what's going on with
interference I want to see some steps
taken some measures taken to defend our
democracy and that would be I think the
consistent approach if one really cares
about defending our institutions our
democracy and making sure we're free
from interference I want to the idea of
the election in just a moment but I want
to ask you ask you Quan when you're
hearing from the Chinese Canadian
community
what is their reaction to how this is
all unfolding in Ottawa and whether they
feel that their concerns are being heard
well the community members that I'm
talking to of course are deeply
concerned with what's going on some of
them I think are also being targeted
already we're seeing the chilling effect
of this I've attended rallies for
example in support of Hong Kong to stand
with the people of Hong Kong with the
unbelievable situation that they are
faced with the National Security Law and
some of them are afraid to speak up some
of them come to these rallies and
they're wearing masks even though we
don't need to wear a mask anymore and
not for health purposes but they're
wearing a mask to protect their identity
some of them have family members in Hong
Kong or in China and they are so worried
about them so their fear is very real
and I see that and I fully recognize it
which is why it is so important for us
to not be silenced for us to step up and
to be that voice and to carry their
voice into the House of Commons
and you can hear more of Mercedes
conversation with the NDP leader and
Vancouver MP Jenny Juan tomorrow on the
west block
in a photoshopped World anyone can be a
victim the scary scam of sextortion
coming up the brave BC teens raising
their voices and calling for action
in an age when technology can put
anyone's face on anyone's body there are
growing calls for accountability from
Big tech companies and major pornography
sites in non-consensual Intimate image
sharing politicians say they're taking
action but some of the younger people
being targeted online say the problems
only getting worse nithu garcha reports
it's like you're it's your fault you
should have known better but how are you
supposed to know if you've never learned
about it these BC high school students
are calling for more education and
resources to prevent and deal with
online harassment and sextortion this is
something that happens really like at a
young age we should talk about it spread
awareness I don't think anyone's safe
like through all different types of
social media pictures get altered they
get taken out of context you know a lot
of editing now like it could be a
different person with a different face
different body looks like they're doing
something completely different more and
more often they say they're hearing
cases of their peers being targeted and
falling victim I think most of the cases
they've never met that person before in
person they just add them on Snapchat
Instagram and start talking to them this
teacher says in a recent case a female
student shared intimate images with
someone she thought was her boyfriend it
wasn't and the stranger blackmailed her
I investigated and started calling
saying why are you not showing up to
school and what's going on and she was
so intimidated she wouldn't leave her
house how often often are you directly
hearing from students about this I
received three to four complaints a week
personally that I dealt with it's why
she says she recently helped form a
committee of teachers to support
victimized youth tonight what we're
going to be talking about is sexting
nudes and intimate images Brandon lore
broadcast live to parents and Educators
he's the CEO of a company dedicated to
providing digital literacy and Internet
safety education this is a financial
strategy that hackers and scammers use
so it's more they're doing it not
because it's for sexual gratification
because they're trying to get money out
of people he hopes help cracking down on
those committing the crimes will come
from a proposed Federal Bill S12 seeking
to make Supreme Court mandated changes
to who's automatically signed up for the
national sex offender registry and
through BC's new law around removing
non-consensual intimate images online
the meeting I've had three so far one
was Google Microsoft and the one most
recently was with the company that holds
PornHub meet geek and what I heard from
them was a commitment to work and abide
by our legislation and will be
continuing to hold them to account in
other companies out there BC's
government hopes focusing on
accountability from the big actors will
help set a safer industry-wide standard
nitugacha Global News Surrey BC
I had the State Farm leaving homeowners
in the U.S in a state of uncertainty how
climate change is changing and halting
insurance policies
California's two decade-long Mega
drought combined with massive wildfires
and record flooding have caused one of
the largest insurance companies in the
U.S to make a drastic decision State
Farm will no longer provide insurance to
new homeowners in the state as Jennifer
Johnson reports experts say this is
becoming a disturbing new trend
California is in a climate disaster
crisis year after year wildfires wipe
out vast areas of the state over 15
thousand wildfires in the past two years
and now weather Whiplash as the state
suffers from record-breaking rainfall
causing catastrophic flooding like a
good neighbor State Farm is there but
now State Farm won't be there the
state's largest homeowner insurer has
just announced it will no longer provide
coverage for new homeowners in
California citing the state's rapidly
growing catastrophe atmosphere it didn't
surprise me but it's unfortunate and
it's not just California across the
country insurers are dropping policies
for people in several disaster prone
States like Florida Texas and Louisiana
where hurricanes tornadoes flooding and
wildfires are costing these companies
billions of dollars each year well I
think it's very troubling and I think it
could be part of a trend State Farm says
it has to protect its Financial Health
as disasters add up in California
climate change experts fear denying or
cutting homeowners coverage could become
the new normal for insurers in the U.S
Canada and other countries as the Earth
heats up what we know very clearly from
years of scientific research is at the
frequency and intensity of extreme
events is
increasing uh it's increasing here in
California it's increasing in other
parts of the US and other parts of the
world in the first quarter of 2023
global insurance companies lost over 15
billion dollars in claims from weather
disasters experts predict millions of
existing California homeowners will be
sent jaw-dropping High rate hikes or
could lose their policies too
unfortunately the law is the insurance
companies have the right as long as they
give you 75 days notice when your policy
comes up for Renewal they can tell you
we're not going to issue you a new
policy homeowners who have lost their
coverage can purchase a policy from
California's FAIR Plan a high risk
Insurance Pool established under state
law but its coverage is limited and it's
very expensive unfortunately for
Millions it could be their only
alternative other than moving out of the
state
Jennifer Johnson Global News Washington
next the big business of Mount Everest
70 years after the first climb Sherpas
speak out on the tallest mountain turned
commercial asset
many people have a dream of climbing
Mount Everest but it's an extremely
risky challenge for those who try in
fact just last week Vancouver Doctor
Peter swart died while descending from
Camp four but among the Heartbreak there
is also heroism as Mike derulolay tells
us the latest tale involves a sherpa who
saved a climber's life in an area known
as the death zone
by the harsh rules of Mount Everest
Sherpa could have left the Malaysian
climber shivering uncontrollably to die
in the so-called Death Zone rescues put
everyone at risk and are considered rare
if not impossible
but the 30 year old refused to walk by
convinced his client to give up his
ascent and hauled the man down 600
meters over six hours
in places where it was rockier we
couldn't drag him so we had to carry him
on our backs he said his heroics kept
the number of climbers who have died
this year on Everest at 12 with another
five still missing making it the
deadliest climbing season in eight years
[Music]
the rescue came at the right time as
celebrations echoed across Nepal to Mark
the 70th anniversary of the first ever
Ascent by Edmund Hillary and Tenzing
Norgay just 35 miles from Kathmandu
Capital of Nepal Hillary and 10 seeing
well welcomed and congratulated by their
fellow members of the Expedition over 6
300 people have since reached the peak
of the world's highest mountain
including nearly 130 Canadians Laurie
stresslet of Calgary was the first
Canadian to stand atop Everest in 1982
but all those climbers would no doubt
Marvel at the greatness of this man
Cami Rita recently set the record for
most descents at 28. the Sherpa his face
blackened by wind and snow Burns was
celebrated in a series of official
ceremonies
but the 53 year old is highly critical
of the way Nepal benefited from Everest
which contributes four percent to the
country's economy permit fees alone for
Everest totaled over 5 million dollars
this year but the Sherpas who followed
in the steps of Tenzing Norgay have seen
little of that money leading Rita to
suggest he's going to immigrate to the
United States
there's no future in Nepal he says so
why are we sitting here
everything about Everest is big the
mountain the heroics and the business
surrounding it mudralay Global News
and that's global national for this
Saturday night I'm Farah Nasser on
behalf of our whole crew here I want to
thank you so much for spending part of
your evening with us tonight's your
Canada is Nanaimo British Columbia until
tomorrow take care of yourselves and
take care of each other good night